tensions in the Gulf region were already
high in this instant has raised them
again according to US defense officials
the instant happened at the northern
entrance of the Straits of Hormuz near
the island of abu musa now the strait is
a vital shipping route linking Middle
East oil producers to markets in the
rest of the world it is just over a
hundred miles long but only 21 miles
wide at its narrowest point and the
shipping lanes are just two miles wide
in either direction so it's a real
potential pinch point daily oil flow in
the Strait of Hormuz averaged 21 million
barrels per day last year that's about a
third of all the oil that was
transported and traded by sea around the
globe now the waters around the island
of abu musa are hotly contested but abu
musa and those waters are controlled by
Iran and according to the Ministry of
Defense the Royal Navy frigate HMS Mont
Rose which was shadowing the British
heritage oil tanker from a distance was
forced to move between the tanker and
the three Iranian boats when they tried
to bring the tanker to a halt as it was
moving into international waters
HMS Montrose is a well armed vessel with
a 4.5 inch main gun and missile system
and a wildcat helicopter on board which
did deploy in this incident the raw Navy
also has in addition to that frigate for
mine hunters and a Royal Fleet Auxiliary
support ship already stationed in a
permanent Naval Support Facility at
mineral man in Bahrain America has an
aircraft carrier the USS Abraham Lincoln
operating in the Gulf of Oman and as
well as a range of other naval assets
the USS boxer is currently in the Gulf
of Aden but this latest incident as well
as escalating tension may add calls to
create a multinational coalition to
safeguard these vital international
waters